[Music]
okay everybody so this is now my spoiler
review of the witcher season two if you
haven't watched the season you can watch
my spoiler free review that is also out
which is also linked below so check that
out first and then come back to this
review when you watch the whole season
and be talking about the whole season so
make sure you've watched every episode
before you watch this uh so let's jump
into this as you could have seen from my
spoiler free review i had only seen the
first six episodes which the only
episodes the press were given early and
i had given it a 9.1 based off that so i
was interested to see adding these last
two episodes that i watched today on
release day where it would bring the
score officially and i would have to say
it would just bring it down a nudge to a
nine and
it's interesting you know running off of
what i said again in my spoiler free
review
i am in the boat what a lot of people
are saying i'm seeing and agree with is
that i really do think episode one was
the best episode i thought it was really
well done now going into that i love the
pure body horror that was in this i love
the bruxa as the villain and
she was terrifying right and i love this
because we only got a little bit of
horror in season one and this season it
really ramped it up and i love that it
was a linear storyline this season i my
biggest complaint with season one was
how confusing it was it wasn't even
something if you watched twice that made
a lot of sense it was just too much and
to go the complete opposite route of
going just linear i thought was the
smart decision i thought it worked
better for a story like this
and it kept the momentum going now where
i'm seeing a lot of disappointment from
fans is in jennifer's storyline but what
i have to say is that i actually like
what they do with their story i think it
made sense because i think if they
didn't they might have run into in this
case in this specific story the superman
problem where she's too powerful i mean
we ended season one where she basically
had this huge burst of power happen and
i feel like they might have ran to
issues in this story that if she was to
meet up with geralt and syrian
situations they were in that she would
be able to solve a lot of these uh
moments and get them out of him too
easily so i thought it made sense she
lost her powers and had to fight through
that where i did think it got sloppy is
we didn't really get a resolution
well about her wanting a child again uh
i thought that was kind of
glossed over and then pushed aside for
wanting her power back so it was strange
though that she did want you know
two things back and that one kind of got
pushed aside for the other with the
wanting magic but
i think that
i see it as season one was really the
jennifer show and i had i was one of
those people in that boat that wanted
more of geralt and you know wanted not
maybe more of siri but to get them
together here that they are here they
need to take the center stage and i like
they did in season two and that a lot of
screen time was given to the two of them
you know maybe with jennifer and yaskir
kind of being pushed to the side a bit
but that was totally fine with me again
because the end of the day the heart of
the story right here is geralt and siri
now what was exciting too going through
the season was that there was just more
monsters there was more fighting with
monsters here it was less talky and it
was more action i think again that works
for a show like this especially a lot of
people like me know it from playing the
video games i haven't read the books so
it's another point i want to make where
what i loved about this season i think
for video game players it was awesome it
looked a lot like the video games
there's a lot of easter eggs to it and
i think that
what i'm seeing is a reaction that it's
very similar to when i cover the wheel
of time another show that's based off a
book and there's just a lot of
negativity towards the season which i'm
shocked but it's actually really coming
from book readers and they hate it and
you know i read the book so i have no
say on that but i do know that
what's frustrating is they'll get one
thing that isn't exactly the same as the
book and they flip out and then they
hate all of it you know and
i think it's different if you're making
an argument of like you know this just
doesn't work as a show or this isn't
good you know but to be mad that it's
different can be frustrating i get you
want to see what you loved and what you
read exactly the same on screen but it's
just not how it works with writing a
show and they have to make it different
it's a different medium it's different
decisions like you it's it's hard for me
to see people so mad about a character
you know of eskel being just killed who
really cares i played the game twice i
still don't remember his character so
i'm not that attacked i'm attached to
maybe when i'm playing the game but when
i watch the show i'm opening my mind to
different possibilities i'm not sitting
there going i need to see what i saw in
the game now maybe where i can relate to
okay i'd be more actually annoyed that
my favorite thing from the game if
you've played the games not really
spoiler but there is a really awesome
villain trio here ladies of the wood and
i have a feeling they just merged into
this created character of the deathless
mother
which is a to me a weird choice of how
because of how good
those villains are from the game i hope
we'll still see them but it is
interesting the similarities about
eating children and stuff like that so i
hope they didn't just kind of decide to
do a lazier route of doing the deathless
mother instead which is a strange
decision to make so maybe i'll take back
some of what i said yeah but again a
character like i skull come on but look
you see the changes they made i thought
they really fixed a lot of stuff from
season one that wasn't great you know
just as simple as triss having red hair
changed everything it changed everything
for the character and it really showed
also how good that actress is because i
think everyone was so distracted by her
looking completely different from the
triss we know so that's an example of
going too far with it right but they did
such a good job at handling siri wanting
to be a witcher the consequences of that
and also her letting go of her family of
the past and embracing her new family
and
jennifer making up for the mistakes she
makes through this season that she is
more flawed here and it's highlighted
more and that she comes to realization
by the end i think that wrapped up well
however i will say the discipline the
finale is that i did think the main
scene came off a little silly the main
battle at the end and i do think it
didn't really hit so hard emotionally as
it should have with yennefer and siri
and geralt where it was in the beginning
with carol and siri in particular and i
thought you know certain things are a
little cheated and silly and corny like
yen got her powers back by doing what
she did and it wasn't totally clear how
exactly that made all that much sense
she just got him back from you know
doing the right thing and taking on
this demon witch and then getting out of
her but now she has her magic so that
felt lazy and
it didn't hit everywhere but
i do think the beginning of the season
was the best i think the first three
episodes were the best and maybe i'll
say episode five as well
um was really good but you know i didn't
really like episode four if you can
remember where that's when yaska first
comes in and it's a lot of jennifer and
the sewers and yet her with the oscar as
well and it kind of felt like season one
to me a lot was a lot of plotting and
talking and not all that interesting and
i can see also the arguments too or like
some of the soviet franceilla just in
general with the elves isn't as
interesting and it needs to be more
interesting for sure but i don't think
it took too much screen time so it
didn't hamper
like so much to me like season one i was
like where's the witcher we're watching
the witcher like i didn't feel that this
season so i think that was a great
decision so that's why i wasn't so
bothered about maybe you know the sea
story lines not being as solid but
that's kind of typical with this show
and i mean there's crazy stuff
throughout just with gore here
especially when frangilla has this big
moment i mean stabbing that guy's eye
was insane and then even that same
episode series eyes bleeding right i i
wasn't expecting i know that was crazy
and it was really cool and i thought
that this season was more confident and
i wasn't afraid to go there with stuff
like that and it's nice they teased the
wild hunt i like they didn't blow their
load here by using all the stuff that's
so popular from the witcher lure
and just teasing it and saving it for
next season and doing a nice reveal with
amir being series dad at the end to get
you excited for the next season so i'm
giving this whole season a nine i think
it's way better than season one which
was what i was looking for it to be i
think it just improved everywhere it
looked better it's bigger budget and i
think people like me who just maybe play
the game or haven't played the game at
all
will
love this and i think it's such an
enjoyable show and you got to just watch
it as a show you know and not worry so
much of what it's based off of because i
think book readers are being way too
hard on it right now but this is what a
lot of book readers do and shows look
i've been on the other side of it i
reviewed that show the outsider i read
the book right before and it made me
hate the show but everyone was telling
me it was a great show i believe you you
know i think there is a weird thing that
happens when you read a book and you you
watch an adaption it's so hard for that
to mesh for you to like both it's just
this weird thing and maybe that only
landed in movies like lord of the rings
and harry potter but otherwise it's
really hard to do or
you can just enjoy it as it is and it's
easier for me to say that because i
haven't read the book so i tried not to
actually read the books before i tried
to read them after for that reason
because books are always better at the
end of the day right like there's so
much more detail you can go on people's
thoughts it's totally different but this
is visual medium this is a different
process it's a different writing process
they're trying to do something different
too so i thought most of it worked here
and again i thought the pace was really
good and i still stand by i think freya
allen was the standout this season and
really stole the show with her acting
abilities and i'm excited to see her
what she can bring for siri as the show
goes on and i'm excited for season three
so let me know what you thought of it
down below i'd love to hear your
thoughts i read every comment and try to
respond as many as i can please make
sure to subscribe so i miss one of my
reviews i'm doing the wheel of time
right now i'm doing dexter i'm also
jumping the yellow jacket soon i also do
movie reviews and i also do celebrity
interviews i got two witcher interviews
coming out later in the week so you're
gonna want to see those i won't spoil
who i'm actually talking to but it is
two actors from the show so i'm excited
for that and please follow me at
stevenshow and twitter instagram and
tick tock for more of me and i'll see
you next time